[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
super excited to be talking about
centrism nuance and so much more we have
will Pappa joining us on the show hello
happy to be here thanks so much for
coming on absolutely super excited for
the sub so for those who don't know
Will's background he's a product manager
and philosopher focused on how new
technologies can help or harm society
you find the links in the by below to
papper dot me as well as the LinkedIn
and Twitter profiles well let's start
things off with one of our favorite
questions to ask her guests what are
your thoughts on the direction of our
world thoughts of the direction of our
world so I think we're at this point
where we have this debate between are we
and a point we're stagnating or are we
in a point of optimism so some people
say hey we have self-driving cars coming
about we have incredible innovations in
computing power we have machine learning
these are all amazing things that will
dramatically change society and then
other people say we're starting
we've already peaked in our productivity
we're starting to hit this point of
decline Robert Gordon for example he
wrote the rise and fall of American
growth his thesis that like since 1970
we've actually been declining in our
productivity and that 1870 1970 was the
peak period of productivity in US
history so it's something where I think
people people's views right now and
they'll say the world depends on whether
you have this optimistic pessimistic
approach this perspective of like things
are changing in great ways or things are
leading to stagnation in turmoil I think
that's where a lot of the current
divisions in society are coming from and
it does seem as though that the the
disconnection that we have from the
ecosystem that sustains us this planet
how it gives us the air the water the
food the resources that we need to live
that the disconnection that we have from
that is directly reflected in the
society's fabric that we live in
how dysfunctional some aspects of it are
do you feel like because of that
disconnect to our ecosystems that we
live in is a reason of the dysfunctions
yes I think that because you have people
with to dramatically different world
views trying to you have two groups with
dramatically different world view is
trying to make decisions on the same
things where if you have an approach of
stagnation your view on for example
universal basic income will be very
different or your view on global warming
will be very different compared to an
optimistic approach and I think that
that is where a lot of the crosstalk
happens where like people miss each
other's points because they have these
different worldviews that they're coming
to the table with and I don't think
that's acknowledged enough yes yes so
okay so then maybe one of the strategies
then would be to unpack people's world
views in nuanced driven ways and to do
it where you can take a complex issue
like like the ecosystems that we live in
and how there are being dysfunctional
because we're disconnected from them or
something like a universal basic income
to solve some of the wealth inequality
issues that we have and instead of being
extremely polarized on it how would you
recommend people to have a more nuanced
urban conversation hmm I I think that
the the reality is but if any the thing
that I learned from philosophy is that
if anything seems simple you're probably
missing a lot that anything simplified
probably is probably is missing crucial
components and extreme simplification is
not the way to go so I think that if you
think you're totally right you should
probably reevaluate that's kind of my
heuristic of these trade-offs are very
complex no one really has the answers to
the stagnation versus optimism question
let's say so that's that's what I use is
my own personal marker for myself is if
I'm think I'm right and if I think I'm
completely right if I can't think of
arguments against what I'm saying I'm
probably missing something yeah I love
that that's a really good way of putting
it is that if I can do things like take
my perspective and also hold
simultaneously the most contrasting
worldview and and then be able to see
both of those at the same time then that
can be really helpful and that's a good
heuristic to is to constantly be looking
for that the opposing side of the
argument and also the the other thing
that you mentioned the beginning which
was a simplification so reductionism
reductionism that this is a good one and
I think we're actually gonna revisit
this later as well but just reductionism
can lead us to oversimplification which
then leaves out the nuanced details so
specific subjects yeah okay let's get
into let's get into the trajectory so um
you know you're born in Manhattan in New
York City you stayed there until you're
18 and went to Wash U and they
transferred to Stanford mmm-hmm
and you did philosophy there I want to
get into your earlier years you got
interested in entrepreneurship through
gaming teach us about building the
online gaming community yeah so yeah
when I was fourteen I set up a just
online game server with some friends and
it was basically like we were playing
Minecraft and doing whatever else we did
at 14 um and it was just we just told
some friends they told some friends and
almost entirely via word of mouth we
grew to around 5,000 people and that was
incredible there's actually literally
people met got married had kids after
meeting on our game server wolf yeah
yeah by the way whenever people ask for
like your fun fact my favorite fun fact
is like I've indirectly led to like
people having a tired
yeah they met on our server and being
able to have that kind of impact on
people's lives was incredible and being
able to just scale something based on
word of mouth was incredible too and I
mean it's we never set out to create
like a giant server we just set out to
create a fun place with our friends and
that kind of made me realize of like oh
you can do something you enjoy you can
have make something impact people and
you can also
hopefully with that didn't make money
but you can also hopefully make enough
money off it to sustain yourself or to
make it profitable so I that that just
showed me whoa like a bunch of friends
just working together can scale
something to five thousand people and
lead to like someone meeting and having
a kid that's that's incredible and that
got me hooked done technology
entrepreneurship in general yeah you
gotta have a purpose that you find
really meaningful and then be able to
provide people with value and also a big
bunny sustain yourself yeah over time
and then what else what else were some
of these things that happened to you
along the way up until doing librarian
AI helping people find expertise faster
with AI and NLP mmm-hmm yeah so back in
high school I had so I finally online
community and there's a group at the MIT
Media Lab that was building a
decentralized mesh network for local
communities and they were like hey like
we see you we see you have experience
with like with building these
communities and I also knew how to code
Java they use Java as a programming
language I like coded some Android apps
they used Android so I had gotten in
touch with them and I was able to do
research at the Media Lab when I was I
think 16 at the time which was an
absolutely incredible experience of
shaped my worldview and it was because
what we're working on was this
technology with pretty incredible
potential the idea was that you could
have phones communicate directly with
each other so you didn't need any cell
service at all to be able to communicate
networks and stadiums that works in
disaster if that works in all sorts of
ways but the privacy trade-offs for
example are really complex in those
technologies there's all these questions
of like how do you verify identities do
you want like strongly verified
identities and then people can't like
speak can't can't speak anonymously do
you want to allow people to speak
anonymously and know that that can come
with some some difficulties in building
a good community and that got me really
interested in the
privacy technologies in the first place
and blockchains
one example of them mesh networking is
another I think there's a lot of a lot
of potential for these technologies that
can do both a ton of good and it kind of
harm depending on their you their use
and that's why I think it's really
satisfying to approach them from a
philosophical perspective and work on
them yeah yeah and so that's where
you're heading into product management
in digital authentication yes yeah and
also doing the kleiner perkins product
fellowship yes that's correct
I like how you taught me that privacy
enables the evolution of ideas that
society the upside evolve I think your
example with like the LGBTQ community
being able to gather in small private
settings and grow I think that's really
important whereas if you had that over
the kind of like Orwellian style of
oversight on people congregating could
prevent them from a society evolving I
think yeah I think privacy fundamentally
anything about privacy is a trade-off
between privacy and security and I don't
think those are easy answers
you know like whatsapp can be used by
the LGBT community can also be used by
terrorists and I think that those are
really really really hard questions of
where do you strike the balance but
fundamentally I don't I don't I don't
know where the balance would lie but I
do believe that privacy helps people
helps people gather shift norms slowly
the progress we see in civil rights a
lot of that comes from the ability to
hold these like hold these views and
attitudes in private and slowly share
them with trusted close friends until
they become public ideas that are
accepted but the security trade-off is
always really really tough and different
countries take different approaches
different people take different
approaches I don't think they're the
right answers but I think that there's
definitely important value in both yes
yes yeah this this exactly this is super
nuanced view on like even something as
simple as a messenger app like whatsapp
with being able to be used to concrete
people to evolve societies or to be used
to cause harm on on writers like mesh
networking because it never touches
a central server there's no there's no
central logging so that means that you
give people communications that can work
anywhere that's a fantastic and that's
the capability to be able to literally
communicate with your neighbors without
needing to pay for an internet
connection have an internet connection
available but it also offers mostly
completely untraceable communication and
is that something you want to is that
something you want to enable mesh
networking community is a good example
of that because like logging is really
important for solving crimes
do you want to for grow that capability
do you want to find a balance do you
want to like offer like
privacy-preserving like central nodes
that are that that that people can opt
in or opt out of but ultimately
transparency in these trade offs is what
really matters
whoo that's a good one you have the
transparency definitely matters a lot
when you're kind of born with just into
the black box and you don't necessarily
know exactly what are the things that
are governing the world that you engage
with yeah this versus if it's
transparent at least and then you can
engage with it maybe augment it may be
trying gather in the private communities
to build things that can obsolete it as
well all right yeah yeah yeah um okay
let's do okay this is good so we're on a
on a philosophy edge it's this cool you
studied Latin wouldn't starting 11
mm-hmm and that it's not only essential
like history to learn but it's also
beautiful on the poetic side of things
now what is the difference between moral
and political philosophy yeah so I see
moral so so political philosophy is
fundamental a question of how do we
organize society what obligations do
governments have to their citizens what
how should people cooperate with each
other how should we approach equality
and inequality and then moral philosophy
in my mind is how do we hold people
responsible within those systems so for
example like should someone should
should someone be held responsible for
the actions of their family and friends
or
should should we not hold people
responsible in the case of accidents
let's say how do we that's those are
like like those are those are tricky
questions like for example if you uh if
you know that someone is doing a bad
thing and you don't report it should we
hold that person responsible for the
consequences of those actions and that
also leads to a really interesting
concept of moral luck
so moral luck is is the idea so let's
say there's two people who are driving
drunk one person gets into a terrible
accident but if there's another person
one person drives home justified is it
fair to evaluate those people based
purely on the consequences they
committed the same action they both
chose to drive drop in one case it led
to a bad consequence that harmed others
in another case it didn't but more or
luck is like should we should we punish
the drug be the drunk driver who didn't
injure someone less just because it
happened to work out okay should we
punish the other person more for their
accident or should there be system that
prevents the driver from driving in the
first place because their blood-alcohol
content you are yes yeah exactly exactly
again privacy and surveillance questions
like do we want to prevent drunk drivers
at all give everyone an integrated
breathalyzer currently the participant
no even though we have the technology
for that exactly so the I think that
that shows that like moral philosophy
you can't just purely evaluate it based
on the consequences it's tough to say
that that that someone is less
responsibly responsible because it
happened to work out okay but then if
you evaluate based on the actions that
also leads to its own trickiness to
because it's like let's say for example
someone is doing something reckless but
that's extremely unlikely to lead to
something bad so like let's say for
example you're in a we're in California
let's say someone is for example
starting a bonfire in like with some
friends in an area that is prone to
wildfires do you want to punish every
person who has started like a small
cooking fire with some friends the same
way as someone who sparks an entire
wildfire
it that's that's again that's again a
tough question because in that case it
wouldn't seem that the that punishing
every person for a bonfire is
appropriate if they didn't spark a huge
wildfire that's where one it seems the
actions could we did tremendous
consequences but punishing never and as
if those consequences occurred seems to
most people to be unjust
it's like reckless for some people who
start a bonfire in a high fire area but
do you want to punish them as if they've
caused the massive devastation or do
they have to have a fire making skill
level at ninety nine before being able
to yeah we're like a threshold of like
twenty years exactly but that also leads
to another interesting question is how
do you measure these things - yeah so
it's nice to be able to say like we
should set this bar for a blood-alcohol
content or we should set this bar for
like fire safety or gun safety or all
these other topics but how do you how do
you take into account the nuances of
different people's approach it's like
let's say someone's really good at
making fires they have tons of
experience handling fire safely but
they're also like goofing around with
friends and not paying too much
attention that might decrease their
skill level to some extent do we do we
do we cut off the threshold at a certain
point we say like oh no matter how
skilled you are if you're like gathering
with 15 friends and like and like like
distracted then you shouldn't be allowed
to start a fire in these areas it's it's
tough - one thing that philosophy he
definitely teaches is these were your
drama lines on definitions is really
really difficult what is good is like a
flaw a question that's been answered
asked throughout all of history and
never answered yes the Greek
philosophers Plato and Aristotle in
particular took a pretty good attempt at
answering those but no one no one has
good answers and right now we've kicked
the can down the road
select utilitarianism for example it's a
branch of moral philosophy thank you
we're hit the ball back on the first
side there's so much to even unpack just
on that thing I love the way that you're
that you go through these examples I
think the
we're gonna have to do more shows on
just these examples of centrism and
nuance because I totally agree with you
that when you have an example like a
motor vehicle and someone that gets away
it's you called it a more luck when
someone gets away with driving drunk
without killing someone so the idea is
then is there a potential way to get
people even pre even entering a car that
prevents them from driving that the food
it maybe gets them to call the uber get
some a friend pick them up or whatever
right so all these other scenarios to
help and then other ones like even to
the fire example a one person cause a
wildfire but millions of people make
fires before that that that go perfectly
fine so how to quantify these things how
to see them in a nuanced way is so so
interesting and then this and then this
does yeah this does kind of um also want
to ask how does psychology influence
more fun yeah so um so there's kind of
two branches of moral philosophy one is
like we about we should evaluate things
purely based on like the appropriate
theoretical frameworks
um utilitarianism is one Kant has
another moral framework and they're kind
of like removing themselves from from
specific situations and just trying to
reason about them abstractly but there
is also another branch which is let's
look at the evidence that we have from
psychology and use that to influence our
decision-making there was a professor I
had at Wash U John Doris who writes on
this heavily and he has fantastic
fantastic books on the subject and the
idea there is like let's look at the
best available evidence that we have and
try to work from there some philosophers
don't like that because they think like
our psychology is constantly being
updated we like don't have a good
understanding yet there's replication
crises so like why should we use those
evidence when we don't know if this
evidence is correct in my mind I take
the other approach which is the best
data we have available is something we
should be using and we should update it
as we get new information so one example
that john doris taught me was on helping
behavior where if for example a lawn
mower is running and someone drops a
stack of books
people are significantly less likely to
help them just because there's this
annoying noise in the environment that's
crazy yeah if someone finds a dime in
the phone booth and someone drops books
they're significantly more likely to
help them yes I'd dive in a phone first
and this these are not experiments run a
long time ago it's roughly the value of
a dime that we that we that we have
today exactly when these such small
things can affect whether we help others
oh the coffee ones another one the you
either give them hot coffee or cold
coffee and yeah and you ask them what
their relationship is like with their
significant other or their parents
exactly and then I think colder coffee
makes people feel a little colder about
them exactly is hot they're more maybe
loving or compassion yes
so for example it's easy to say like we
should always help others or we have an
obligation to help others but when the
data shows that a lawnmower running
makes us less likely to help others are
we comfortable making these
pronouncements about how people should
act which kind when the environment so
heavily influences them yes which
totally makes sense because when you
have two humans that are in a quiet
setting and something occurs your your
cognitive resources are really only
being allocated to just a year or
presence and someone else's presence and
helping them in that scenario versus
when there's so many other things
happening in the background you're kind
of like making sure that nothing is
about to harm you or like something's
gonna fall on you or whatever like
there's so many other things something
could break over here it's just loud
like a loud environment lots of
different things going on you have to
like also keep things in your proof
reason one yeah so so that's a good one
and then I just want to also say on the
on what you're just saying that
depending on so many aspects of
psychology of our biology like yeah a
tumor pressing on the amygdala causing
someone to go and potentially kill
someone things like this yeah that
there's so many aspects that we have to
be aware of and biases yeah that we have
to be aware of in the processes of
philosophy mmm-hmm yeah I think that uh
again this gets back to the central
point of nuance really which is where
trying to trying to predict how we act
or how others act is actually extremely
extremely difficult and our
understanding of the factors influencing
people is currently extremely rough so
incentives your gut microbiome there's
like so exactly and we we understand
almost none of it so I think using the
best the best assumptions we have right
now and working from there's the best
data available is what we should do I
don't think we should ignore this
important important background because
again if you think that someone should
always act in a certain way so comp is
famous for saying like you should never
ever lie like because like like and the
examples oh it's like well like let's
say someone is like like let's say let's
say you like hold nuclear launch codes
and someone's threatening you and being
like oh you need to get do you know the
launch codes if so you need to give them
to me
Khan would say you cannot lie and say I
don't know the nuclear launch codes yes
of like trying to make time to make
counters yeah
exactly that are super EXTREME misses
the new law exactly so I I think I think
that's why that's why the psychological
element is really helpful because it
helps us think through some of this
additional nuance and maybe additional
understanding of neuroscience we'll
change our assumptions later on that's
perfectly possible I think we can give
another example I think super relatable
to people which is that like most people
have maybe like parents that are not
necessarily as potentially it
progressively evolved as they are as
their children are in some respects and
so when their parents maybe ask them a
question about one of their like beliefs
or whatnot if they can rather just you
know kind of like sidestep that like
you're not maybe you're lying maybe your
site's having but the point is is that
you can kind of you're saving time by
not having to go into a subject that you
have maybe a dozen times before with
them that you know you're not going to
be able to make any progressive ground
on so you'd rather just go back to like
reading or working on what you there
about and hanging out
your friends that care about that same
thing so I think there's tons of of
nuance around that point yeah yeah like
something that's technically correct
they're lying by omission like that
those it's easy for count to say to
never lie but if you like if you if you
don't actively lie but you just choose
not to disclose something it's not also
lying I mean that's you could do a lot
of you could do a lot of philosophical
work to try to figure out if that is or
you could say that we should hold
anyone's more nuanced perspective of
like how we view how we view truth and
lies yeah yeah yeah whoa again another
hole we have to we have to explore these
ideas more in these examples of these
more this has so much to do with
philosophy with our yeah with our
psychology and our biology as well as
the nuance of centrism let's do the best
ways to organize society yes okay so
what are the differences between and so
this is the political philosophy side of
things what are the differences between
the Talat Arianism rossi and liberalism
libertarianism yes so uh I'll start with
utilitarianism first because I was kind
of the first theory that came about so
utilitarianism
is basically says you should try to
maximize net good Jeremy Bentham what's
one the original thinkers on this Peter
Singer is a modern thinker on
utilitarianism and it's basically you
should try to maximize like happiness
for everyone so you shouldn't prioritize
say like let's say there are three
people drowning
and you can save two people and they're
strangers or you can save one person and
they're you're there like you're your
mother or father utilitarianism would
say you should try to save you should
save the two people who are strangers
instead of the one person who's your
parent and
utilitarians then go into all these
different thought experiments of like
for example like if there's a doctor who
is a serial killer but also it's on the
way to curing cancer are they saving
more lives than they're killing by
they're like their curative cancer
compared to being a serial killer like
should you let them walk free so
utilitarianism leads the very tough
moral trade-offs that's that's one issue
with it yeah yeah another one is like
okay would you potentially do something
like save five people's lives versus
save the live life of someone that's
trying to do something like your cancer
yeah yes stuff like that like how can
you value someone's impact on the
trajectory of the world yeah providing
utility to the world versus my example
that maybe not providing there's a great
book called strangers drowning and that
uh addresses it sounds correctly that's
not name of the book yes yeah it's it's
a very good book on these questions and
very very approachable for people who
don't lastly won't ground cool cool but
yeah so utilitarianism and then there's
the whole question of how do we define
net good like should you save should you
save a doctor for example over someone
else should you save like children over
elderly people because the children will
have longer lives
so you Tillett Arianism leads a lot of
these tough questions and a lot of
people don't have answers so rosy and
liberalism kind of came about as an
answer to this so Rawls basically says
that um you should have yeah he's that
sort of few obligations to society but
I'll call it like the most important
ones one is that uh you should have
equality of opportunity basically like
you should have the ability to to to the
ability to not be kept out of things
based on like your gender your race your
birth religion socioeconomic status
exactly exactly like these things that
these things that you can't control and
what also don't affect your ability to
do a job he's like you should have a
society where everyone's able to access
like important roles inside maximal
degrees of economic freedom yes and
related that he also has the idea that
um inequality is justified when it
maximizes the position of the people who
are the least well-off so for example if
someone if there's a society where like
evarin where one person has a hundred
dollars and everyone else has ever in
house has two dollars Rawls would say
that that's okay if
that that inequality is okay as long as
there's as long as it's the best
possible outcome so for example let's
say like you said that person should
have $100 they should have $50 but that
led to everyone else having one having
$1 instead of $2 or else would say
you're sure that we're all would say
it's better for everyone to have $2 and
further rapport that's more significant
inequality to occur if it maximizes the
position the people release off but if
there's a world where someone controls
but it and that those are those are the
really most relevant points of Rawls and
the humans flourish when the people that
are least well-off have the most degrees
of economic freedom yes and closely
related to idea that he has and this is
this is kind of an idea here like
liberal political thought in general is
like the freedom to pursue one's own
projects yes so like people have their
own conceptions of what is good they
should be able to do what that is if
they want to host the podcast
interfering thought leaders that is a
fantastic that is a fantastic thing they
should have a 3d me to pursue if they
want to go become phosphors that's
something they should have the freedom
to pursue if they want to even count the
blades of grass and alone and they think
that's a good life they should have the
freedom to pursue that so it essentially
allows people to form the project that
they think is best for the world and
sustain on counting the blades of grass
along yeah yeah we will probably get to
universal basic income later and then
and then there's libertarianism and
libertarianism says like the obligations
of a government are not like are not
like the freedom to pursue ones on
projects and equality of opportunity but
it is like Robert Nozick libertarianism
is that like government should purely
basically purely protect like life and
property and that it should be a minimal
state beyond that and there's this
interesting question
Rawls thinks that you should interfere
to create an equal playing field so
someone should not be allowed to
discriminate in hiring because those
jobs should be up in everyone well
Nozick thinks that like that's okay
because you're restricting the freedom
of the person who is doing the hiring
so they have different approaches of who
should have which freedoms which is a
really really complicated question the
person that owns all the property that
is being protected by the government is
also doing things like rent-seeking on
the people that are least well-off like
these there needs to be an intervention
to help the people have better degrees
if I can exactly exactly so like whose
freedom are you preserving it's a really
important question between those two
theories and a one fun little known fact
about Nozick so Nozik actually so
there's a lot of talk in the media about
reparations reparations for
african-americans were affected by
slavery Nozick actually says that like
society must come from a just starting
point for this libertarian society to be
just so you must have basically like
free and voluntary transfers of property
from the starting point until now
slavery was not a free involuntary
transfer at all it was treating people
as property which is incredibly unjust
and and the interesting thing is that
knows like actually alludes to the fact
he doesn't say that he he doesn't say
explicitly that like reparations should
be pursued but he does say that
reparations are important but because
these and justices have preserved for a
- because these and justices have
occurred to have this libertarian
Society so like like when people talk
about like libertarianism in America
that's not news X libertarianism because
we haven't had it we haven't set this
equal starting point exactly which is
really interesting and I think that also
gets lost a lot of discussion of like I
mean there's other libertarians who
believe that like the starting point we
have right now is a just one but like
specifically Nozick's libertarianism
would not would not support
libertarianism today we would need to
equal the playing field before we can
pursue it which i think makes it a lot
more palatable when compared to RLC and
liberalism because the idea of like if
we said right now like it's okay to do
it it's okay to like for example like
discriminate based on socioeconomic
status
that would be incredibly unjust when you
look what's up bang which is what
happens yeah which is that our be
incredibly unjust because people have
been held back from accumulating wealth
based on the actions of the government
and private enterprise and just greedy
corrupt mess and general rent seeking
behaviors self-dealing behavior yeah
rosalie dynamics yeah so many of these
aspects that have been the one thing
that I think you said that I think
everyone can resonate with is that the
society will flourish best when the
people that are worst off have the most
degrees of freedom when they're taken as
like these are literally our fellow
humans that we can help maximize their
potential and so to view it that way I
think is one of the best things of
versus yeah basically what it seems like
at times is that literally moats or
walls are being created that prevent
people from pursuing things purposely by
people that are again self dealing and
always saying I personally lean towards
the rousing approach but I think that I
think that there's validity to all of
these approaches yet they all they all
have different setting points different
trade-offs like this is definitely going
to be a theme we keep er training - I
love ya good yeah and then if we we were
trying to get to some things that were a
little bit of you know we've kind of
started exploring some of the things
that our net good or yet evil but do you
think there's something else that's just
coming through humans that is evil that
is at play on the planet like if there
is there something evil in the world
right now yeah and even potentially
beyond the planet that is coming through
humans that is performing evil on the
planet interesting um I I think that
that depends on people's own personal
views of like spirituality and good and
evil III I personally would like would
would uh III I personally don't know my
own thinking on this and probably like
if I don't know my own thinking I'd lean
towards evidence but I think that um i
think that i think that like the problem
of evil in the world is like
a very very a very very tough problem to
understand and I think that it's it's
it's it's interesting how like if you
think about it like a society a society
with like wherever and cooperated
perfectly wherever and maximized
everyone's interests like let's say like
a utilitarian society where like ever
and lived the utilitarianism would be a
society without depending on how you
define it without evil without like
people harming others let's say we
wanted to find evil that way but at the
same time like we have a world where
there is clear unnecessary harm there is
like harm from poverty harm from
oppression harm from things on those
lines and those those harms that occur
don't seem to maximize the good of the
world like harm through poverty and
significant equality does not seem to
maximize the good of the world like
that's where the rousing approach is
good of like of like we should be
maximizing the position with people who
are the least well-off because that's
probably a better world than a world
where people are in more extreme poverty
let's say yeah and I'll another I just
another thing that I really like about
what how you take on certain subject
matters is you like you kind of know
where your worldview is and then you
know that if someone potentially asks
you a question that you haven't
necessarily thought about like a lot
that then you'll default to saying that
you know I haven't thought about that
enough and I think that is a very humble
way that I think more and more people
can embody behaving because our
worldview obviously doesn't have answers
to everything so it's very important
Socrates famously both acknowledged that
he knew nothing and also thought that he
was the wisest person for that
acknowledgement yeah so we were talking
a lot of experimentation in organizing
society systems of governance across the
planet they're kind of like little
permutations that are running across and
like we can kind of figure out what the
best lines of code are across the u.s.
or China or certain African philosophies
or South America
these are wherever around the world and
I think that's a really interesting way
of viewing is how can we potentially
make little special economic zones with
these different lines of code and see
how they evolve and I think that's
definitely going to be a future of like
the little pockets that are competing in
terms of what what places people want to
live and what are the regulations in
those areas I think that's a really good
way of putting you were actually in a
class at Stanford taught by Peter Thiel
and Russell of Berman called sovereign
tree
sovereign tree and globalism
globalization and I think this is a
really interesting point that we were
talking about before we started that
nationalism globalism don't really
understand each other
yes it's teach us about that yeah so so
I'll start with so so I'll start with
how how how each side defines their own
viewpoint so nationalism views
themselves like enabling experimentation
among different countries so systems of
governance for example like the US and
China have radically different
approaches to governance we don't know
which one's the better approach right
now and it's best to have a world where
these countries can try to figure out
what the best way what's the best way to
organize the world is nationalism sees
themselves as like preserving state
sovereignty to allow to allow these
experiments to happen and that's how you
really make progress that's how you
discover what the best options are
globalism see is there to be significant
downsides from some of those
experimentation from from that
experimentation and it's better to have
a universal organizing principle that
promotes peace for example like how how
a lot of these international
institutions preserve peace rather than
war and they see nationalism as
nationalism as something where like you
could lead to societies where they are
like they're they're not good for their
citizens
and like should we should we should we
should we prioritize a system where like
countries could do bad things their
populations as well as good things and I
think the issue is that both sides like
really really don't but both sides
really are kind of talking past each
other that's won't take away I got from
the class so for example the nationalism
believes in preserving state sovereignty
and they as long have imperialist which
was as long as it's not imperialist yeah
there's a book the virtue of nationalism
that tries to define it as basically
nationalism is these is when these
countries like have their own
experimentation and and then that if
they are if they try to impose their
will on other countries that's actually
not nationalism that's imperialism and
that would fall more on the on the
standpoint of like globalism instead
it's imposing your will in other
countries this is so interesting
thinking about like tribes that are
first evolving on the planet and how
they have their own like little kind of
like pockets of like nationalistic
beliefs as long as they don't go and try
and conquer other tribal areas but
rather in maybe they can also have a
globalized ideology where they have like
free trade between that show exactly
yeah and then there's also then there's
there is there is the globalist approach
which is where you say these
international institutions are what
preserve the peace they might like for
example protect smaller countries that
can't defend themselves and that
nationalism saying that nationalism
preserves state sovereignty is incorrect
because if if a larger country invades a
smaller one like we should do something
about it we should set up systems to
prevent this so like I think the key
problem is like what happens when
countries don't respect state
sovereignty yes nationalism says that's
like that's that's an imperialist
problem that's that's on the that's on
the global side and then globalism says
like actually that's a that's a problem
of nationalism that's because we don't
have these international institutions to
protect these countries so they're kind
of like both claiming that the biggest
downside is the other the other side's
the other side's the other side it's
like a responsibility the other side and
I think that um until he's like
definitional questions get sorted out
we'll just have people talk past each
other for a while yeah it's a nuance
unpacked it's very understandable way
both both of them it's a question of
what better preserve state sovereignty
like an international institution with
some rules and norms but that like
protect small countries from being
invaded or a system where different
countries can experiment and they
believe that these countries
experimenting won't lead to invasions of
other countries because that's that
that's actually an imperialistic
imperialist action it's it's a I think a
big game of risk up until this point yes
yes yeah so I think that it's that's
something that's a very significant
divide in society and it's tough to make
progress in these discussions when both
sides view the problems as the as the
responsibility the other side not their
side yeah but yeah that's that's another
area where like these are these are very
complicated trade-offs and the
responsibilities of like who protects
what protects these smaller states
correct is a really really really good
really hard yeah yeah I think a
potentially a good example could be that
when you look at unlike an indigenous
tribe somewhere that is that someone is
trying to colonize that area where they
are like how can other people from
around the world intervene in a way that
does not cause a massive war but that
still protects the indigenous tribe yeah
so it's like this and I personally I I
personally don't take a stance on which
one is right in these questions I just
think that like we need a better
understanding of what even these two
sides are saying before we can start to
understand which way is a better
organizing principle and pressing reset
on civilization and trying to see how
the game of Risk could have not evolved
in a you know imperialistic in a
colonized in a pillaging and plundering
resources murdering people sort of way
is one of my favorite sort of ideas of
simulation is really trying to think
back like how could have we evolved in a
way that was more harmonious with nature
with each other
yeah these types of and each side that
harmony is actually the perfect example
each side thinks that their approach is
more harmonious nationalism sees it as
all these independents
in states that can choose to collaborate
how they wish and that they can choose
to choose to choose to operate systems
of governments governance as they wish
and then the the the the globalism
standpoint says like actually what's
more harmonious is uniting these states
together under a system of common rules
and that's it
preserving the peace under either system
is a really really difficult question
but they both are trying to seek ways
for different people to live in harmony
they just have different approaches of
how to do it yeah yeah yeah definitely
weren't my favorite parts about our
conversation together it's just how much
you are literally the embodiment of like
centrism and it's like I love that
because I I've changed the middle name
of myself across the platforms to nuance
purposely to try and get more people to
think about things in this way mm-hmm
let's talk about how crypto currency
changes governments and the best funding
mechanisms for ubi yes so crypto
currency change governments so there's a
great book on this called the sovereign
individual it was written it was written
before 2000 and actually predicted all
of the cryptocurrency revolution that we
see today
um the interesting thing about the
sovereign are believed that sorry its
sovereign individual that I think people
under value with the whole
cryptocurrency revolution is the
sovereign individual views
cryptocurrency as a threat because
governments cannot tax it it's a threat
to the current system of governance
because of that because it's it's it's
money that can be moved easily in some
cases moved untraceable II yes and that
acts as a direct direct threat to the
current the current systems that we have
the sovereign individual believes that
this will the the book believes that
this will lead to government's
essentially competing for winning over
citizens of like we and this this kind
of ties into our nationalism in
globalism discussion from earlier like
it they believe that governments will
like put forward different incentives to
start different industries or to get
people to move there and that
governments will serve their citizens
best if they have this like basically
like competition for citizenry between
each other
then but on the other hand like if
there's the power if governments lose
the pirate attacks that could also lead
to like more like like more oppression
or like the bending of these
technologies in an attempt to preserve a
status quo and there's I think this also
works really interestingly in terms of
like special economic zones which I am
fascinated by but have not read deeply
on so this is this is this is just my my
off-the-cuff thoughts on this is that
like special economic zones are
essentially a way to say like hey we
think that this system might be an
interesting system to try yep we're
gonna put it out there people can choose
to participate in it or not yep and it's
it's interesting how how how the US does
not really pursue this I mean the
federal system of like allowing States
to pour different regulations and
policies is one way to do it
China has the approach of special
economic zones for specific cities it's
it's it's interesting how there's
there's the question of like how much
leeway do you give on a local level and
how much do you preserve at a federal
level and different countries have
different approaches but I think this
experimentation is important and I think
that this experimentation of testing
different methods of how to live is not
is not done enough especially in the
United States it seems like
cryptocurrency and decentralization
technologies are coming in as the exact
contrast or entices
to what happened with setting up like
the Federal Reserve and things like that
and having fiat currency circulate
around the world and these types of
things so you're right though on tax on
taxation you know how does how does a
country figure out how to how to do that
and support its construction of roads
and police stations fire stations all
these types of different hospitals at
least of schools there so so it's
actually difficult to figure out but
could there potentially be a way to
figure out how to how to do that I think
with the addition of cryptocurrencies I
think that would be
fantastic let's go to ubi best funding
mechanisms for ubi which ones are even
politically feasible yes yeah so there's
there's a bunch of different ideas for
funding ubi
and I think they all have their they
they there's one I personally am in
favor of but there's some caches to it
that I'll get to so the first approach
is like let's tax let's tax Labor's like
let's tax people's work and we'll use
that directly to fund a ubi that in the
case of massive job loss leads to
reciprocity concerns so the concern is
like will the people who are working be
opposed to a ubi because they feel like
they're working and other people aren't
and that their money is being taken from
them and given to others there's there's
concerns around taxing taxing taxing
labor in that way because of questions
that people have of fairness and then of
course there's the flipside of fairness
of like if someone if there's so much
job loss that some people are just
unable to find jobs at all is it fair to
have the people who are still working
like think that they are entitled to
more when some people again just based
on low lack of like how they happen to
be born into certain circumstances or
the skills that they happen to learn
that like became irrelevant should they
should they be punished were those when
in another scenario they easily could
have ended up being perfectly okay then
there's the other approach of like do we
tax capital do we tax do tax companies
directly and I mean that that has
similar trade-offs towards taxing labor
the third approach that is under
discussed in the ubi literature but one
that is really really interesting to me
is instead creating a citizen's dividend
or social dividend this is done for
example in Alaska Alaska based on the
revenue based on the revenues that they
received from their oriole resources
have invested those and then give every
person I think two thousand dollars a
year the Eastern Band of Cherokees has a
casino that is able that that generates
enough revenue to give every member of
the tribe nine thousand dollars
I think I think $9,000 per year which
gets pretty close to Andrea Aang's
proposal of $12,000 per year
I think another approach that we could
take to funding universal basic income
is to start investing this money now
from say like investing in companies
that are too in the technology industry
or investing in things that investing in
industries that we think might grow if
automation occurs and then using the
profits from those investments to
distribute it back to the citizens so
the idea is like let's tax everyone now
well everyone well many people have jobs
put that money away for a while and when
there's massive job loss we paid out
based on the investments that the
government has made there's ways to do
this in ways that preserve free markets
this is interestingly enough this is
both a both this could be taken as both
a libertarian idea and a socialist idea
the socialists say you're buying stakes
and companies won't be off the
government to give citizen shares of
them the libertarians say it's a the
best way to avoid taxation and to
preserve people's choice and it's the
best way to preserve the free market
it's it's interesting the implementation
matters a lot in in in in in basically
like which for you you take on but this
is my own personal take on the best way
to find ubi this is not as discussed in
literature as the other options but of
course the catch is that it raises a lot
less money the only other options so
that's the real trade-off is like this
thing that sounds like everyone wins
like let's tax ever no let's put the
money away for a while let's distribute
it when things are one people are worse
off you might not have that much money
to distribute and you might need to lean
on other funding sources as well
you will need meaningful endeavoring
every single day when they wake up to
that's a yes part of this that's that's
and that's another debate in when it
comes to automation as some people think
that automation will automation plus
universal basic income will free people
up to pursue like this Rousey and
conception of their own version of the
good life like you can wake up every day
and make art or volunteer or do whatever
else you want and then other people are
like the work and the paid work is what
provides the
an indian meaning when you lose that um
you-you-you-you lead to people like you
know the classic example say like what
if people use it to buy drugs or
whatever people like sit on the couch
all day and play video games studies
show that that tends to not happen but
there's there's this approach of does
job loss in able freedom or does it harm
people's freedom and dignity and that
you can see that directly in the current
proposals some some proposals that
Congress is talking about and these are
all more like or these are more
discussions right now nothing close to
being law is let's give people jobs and
say infrastructure similar to what we
did on the New Deal like let's let's
have people focused on focused on
specifically like let's let's focus on
offering work if people wanted and then
the other approach is like why force
people into work when they could be
doing other things things that are
difficult to value like if someone's
taking care of their children they're
taking care of their parents we can't
really put a dollar amount on that
easily but we can't say that's a
valuable thing to do so why don't we
help people make decisions on what they
personally value and that is hopefully
more meaningful than the idea of paid
work complicated future with
distribution of figuring out how to do
wealth inequality figuring a little
cryptocurrency has to do with this yeah
yeah figuring out how automation is
gonna play out into this picture yeah
cryptocurrencies an interesting London I
never made this connection before but if
you if you if you do believe a
cryptocurrency will harm the
government's ability to tax and you also
believe that funding ubi requires some
substantial increase in taxation if
those two things conflict that's it's a
it's we're talking about two unlikely
scenarios in a future area like
cryptocurrencies dominant and harms
taxation and also where there's massive
job loss in automation but it's not
impossible and I think what happens then
no one as far as I know there's not any
literature on this no-one's really
thought about that but if anyone
watching is interested in what how do we
how do we how do we fund a ubi when we
can't tax people and there's also
massive job loss yeah that's a that's
that's a scenario that
play out ya tendencies to maybe want to
give in to the helping people that
increase their degrees of freedom
there's all different types of potential
yes solutions um how about are we in a
simulation yes irena simulation that yes
was yes to like that's a great question
not uh I don't I don't I I personally
think that like I don't know what the
likelihood of if we're in a simulation
or if we not or if or not is but I do
think that there's really interesting
questions related to this so I I agree
with most room that like it's possible
that you know that three scenarios are
possible one is that society will never
advance the point where the where where
simulation of a universe is possible
another is that it will advance that
point and we're the first society to do
so and another is that another society
has already advanced that point and and
we are in a simulation because they were
they were first and we weren't I don't I
don't know which ones most likely but I
think there's a really interesting
underexplored implication of the third
option that like that another Society
advance this point first and we're in
the simulation and so Boston presents a
few reasons for why we might be living
in it similarly why society might like
bother to simulate us it seems like a
rather difficult project to undertake
one one per one potential he gives is
like that the society values human life
and like values the idea of like more
human life existing being better but I
think that's a tough one because like
then why is there death and why is there
evil and why is there suffering if the
value is human life like why aren't we
all living in the Garden of Eden like
perfectly blissful perfectly happy
perfectly ignorant like why do we have
the like somewhat like like broken world
what we have right now so if if the
simulation exists because we value human
life
I think there's unanswered questions
about the problem of evil and boaster
him like kind of he addresses these but
I don't think the answer is totally
satisfying like he says like well maybe
the idea of pain itself is simulated but
he has this really
really really really amusing aside where
he says like and this is not much
consolation to the people who are
currently experiencing pain so like it's
easy to say like maybe there's not
actually suffering because the the pain
itself is not so many people are having
but like if you have the conscious
experience of pain as everyone does then
like it's tough to take that stance and
boast erm kind of leaves that unanswered
the second approach is like maybe they
want to learn something from us being in
the simulation maybe maybe they're
experimenting with systems of governance
ways to organize society what happens if
you have these ideas yep and in my mind
there's two scenarios there one is that
the its dependent on us not knowing
we're in a simulation which could
explain like why it would be impossible
to discover this fact and bus term talks
about how the system can create the
appearance of consistency by for example
when you look under a microscope it
bothers to like simulate all of the
organisms aside but when you just stare
at a glass of tap water you it's not
bothering to simulate it to reduce
processing power that it requires so if
we if we're if we're in a simulation
that depends on us not knowing that
we're in a simulation or I would be why
would we be allowed to think of the idea
of a simulation in the first place so if
we're supposed to be ignorant of this
fact why can we think of it at all
that's what makes a game fun exactly and
if we and and then if it depends on us
or if it if it's neutral to us realizing
we're in a simulation then why haven't
we been able to figure it out yet all
right hard to probe exactly the
simulation yeah so either trying to
receive us in which case it seems easier
to just never allow people to think of
this idea in the first place or it's not
trying to deceive us in in which case
it's unclear why we don't have answers
yet unless the answer is like we need
our research methodologies to develop
more we ourselves are an experiment and
we ourselves will be creating
experiments and then it would be more
potentially easier for us to realize
that how we're already in one as we make
our yeah yeah I think oh well why would
you just make it the Garden of Eden well
that's not fun we need to add the good
and the evil to it and that's what makes
them in the simulation have more right
and that's what we're in maybe the
answer simulation is trying to learn
something from us if we are in a
simulation in which case the question is
what would they be trying to learn they
would be in many ways trying to learn I
think how a civilization evolves yeah
how civilizations evolved around this is
a very fun one these little planets
around stars like this little universe
designed then there's other ideas of
universe design where different
creatures could evolve in different ways
and then last question is what is the
most beautiful thing in the world yeah I
think that it's still staggering to me
like how much of our the world around us
has actually imagined like based on
these like collective collective actions
like all the philosophies fundamentally
imagined like it's imagined based on
certain starting points certain axioms
and then beyond that it's like you're
talking about entire ways to organize
how people live based on these abstract
ideas like there's no there's no there's
no physical instantiation of
utilitarianism it's just this idea that
exists there's no like Rawls thinking up
I think we're all slinking up the idea
that he did has a dramatic influence I'm
like actually like whether people are
happy whether people are suffering I
think the ability to come up with these
concepts that like don't exist at all in
any physical form yet still influence
the physical world are like something
that these imagined realities are still
kind of kind of staggering to me of like
someone thought up the idea of the
nation so now we have Nations there's no
reason there's borders for example or
like borders or races or things like
that there's like it is they exist
because of the categories and things on
those lines that we've defined and you
could define different categories you
could define no categories at all I
think people on different sides of the
political spectrum take very different
approaches like whether these categories
exist how they should be defined but
it's interesting to me just like the
most the most beautiful thing is that
like we've constructed a world well
beyond what just physically exists
around us and I don't think we
acknowledge that enough and that's why
if
if I line the call to action for my
study philosophy well the reason to
study philosophy is because a lot of
these questions of how we should live
our lives how society should be
structured like whether what is good and
evil there are things that we will never
be able to find in the physical world I
mean some people have the idea of like
maybe with a perfect understanding of
human brain will have like is eliminated
the human brain will have a scientific
idea of happiness stuff like that but I
I think like that
these questions really come down to like
how we imagined the world would be what
first principles we take on and how it
should how we should move forward based
on that yeah and philosophy is one of
the only tools we have to to explore
that I think that there is because so
much of our world is socially
constructed there's limits to what
science can tell us and philosophy is
helpful for probing those limits and
understanding what we take for granted
and what we don't and that's what you
think is most beautiful the fact that
the fact that we have imagined these
structures that exist that allow us to
cooperate but then also that we have
tools in place to shape and probe these
systems and you can change for example
like utilitarianism can change the world
purely based an idea of how we should
live if if people adopt this idea of
maximizing that good whether or not
that's the best approach to live is
unclear and also a role of philosophy
but let's say people adopt as approach
for maximizing that good and they they
take that on
you've changed dramatically people's
lives based purely on an idea that
Jeremy Bentham thought up a few hundred
years ago yeah that's that's that's that
green yes yes Darfur is its philosophy
the path to the most influential career
I think there's a small number of
philosophers who are extremely
influential Peter Singer Jeremy Bentham
Conte the Greek philosopher is Rawls
then there's a lot of philosophers who
are not influenced at all but I think if
you if you if you if you want if you
wanted low probability but extremely
high impact potential path in life
thinking about these ideas and studying
them either formally or informally is a
very good way to do it yeah mm-hmm well
thank you so much for coming on the show
yeah you're pretty and fantastic
absolutely a good time yeah super fun
time the only subjects that you huge
shout out to everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it we would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on that episode let us know what you
think about everything from privacy
centrism and nuance organizing society
all of the different things we talked
about cryptocurrencies ubi simulation
iboss there's so much of the good stuff
just let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode also
talked to more people your friends
families co-workers kept online on
social media about these subjects get
talking about them more have that nuance
centric discourse about it not for as
discourse about it
shoutout to ron Vargas for producing and
directing the show we greatly appreciate
it Ron and also support the artists
entrepreneurs the organization is a
scientists around the world that you
believe and support them help them grow
check out the wheels links below
also check out simulations links below
support us patreon PayPal cryptocurrency
all our links are below design cool
merchants get pay for it that link is
below as well and go and build the
future everyone manifest your dreams
this is where I'll do love you very much
think you're tuning in we will see you
soon
[Music]